johnny depp's staff defamation trial
against his former wife that would be
amber hurd is set to take a very
dramatic turn this week cbs news has
confirmed there will be a surprise new
witness and it's another famous name the
trial is about whether depp was abusive
to amber hurd he says that he was not
jonathan vigliotti reports on why depp's
lawyers hope this new testimony could be
the key to winning this defamation case
supermodel kate moss who dated johnny
depp in the 90s is expected to be called
to testify as a witness by depp's legal
team in the libel trial against his
ex-wife amber heard earlier this month
hurd testified that during a fight in
2015 she recalled an alleged incident
where depp was rumored to have pushed
moss down a staircase i just in my head
instantly think of
kate moss and the stairs
and i
swung at him depp's lawyer benjamin chu
was spotted pumping his fist when heard
mentioned moss during her testimony the
name drop allows depp's team to call her
as a witness since moss's testimony
became relevant after heard testified
about what she believed happened to her
cbs news legal analyst ricky clemen you
know that johnny depp's lawyers know
that kate moss will be a terrific
witness for johnny depp and that kate
moss will say she was never pushed by
johnny depp in any way let alone down
the stairway on monday the jury listened
to testimony from a psychiatrist who
supported herd's claims of being a
victim of emotional and physical abuse
mr deb has behaviors that are consistent
with both someone who has a substance
use disorder as well as consistent
behaviors for someone who is a
perpetrator of intimate partner violence
depp who has denied abusing his ex-wife
was expected to be called to the stand
by heard's lawyers yesterday that did
not happen but it's a move herds defense
is still considering amber heard's
attorneys have the opportunity to call
back johnny depp to the stand they
declined to do that why do you think
i can't imagine what would have ever
gone through the minds of amber heard's
attorneys to even consider calling
johnny depp during their own case
johnny depp if he gets back on the
witness stand will be a good witness for
johnny depp not a good witness for amber
hearn lawyers for depp however are
planning to have him take the stand
again this week ahead of closing
arguments on friday
for cbs mornings i'm jonathan vigliotti
well it's always interesting when you
add another famous name to this picture
and ricky's right they wouldn't call
kate moss if they didn't think she was
going to say something very positive in
johnny depp's favor yeah i think that's
what the fist pump meant for the lawyer
but why are we all so fascinated with
this case because they're famous because
of the details it really i think it's
all of the above all of it a friend
asked me the other day he said what are
you binge watching i said the herd and
depth case yes and that's what i've been
doing on the weekends yes